anyone anywhere can just start serving
Mr Beast Burger you just take our
training course order our ingredients
see that that's not the best endorsement
for his restaurant anyone anywhere could
just start cooking burgers for us
all you need is a spatula and us and
some kind of fire as long as the fire
hot enough you in business or maybe not
sometimes it come raw and that's just
the way it is with Beast Burger King and
then turn it on all the websites so it's
the same ingredients oh so it tastes the
same and I understand what Jimmy's
trying to do you really shouldn't make
it that accessible for anyone anywhere
to start serving Mr Beast Burger to
customers because again I started
thinking about the health inspection
stuff people all over the country
primarily kids are eating this food you
need to have some kind of barrier for
the quality of it